dad's like yeah what else I think it was
like things to tell I just wanna know
what my dad yeah Bruce brown he's seven
roots around Chris Brown sick patient
he's still writing about tech oh yeah I
remember you told me this prolific tech
writer has an awesome elderly age anyway
halo 5 guardians has a new update on
both consoles and PC but most notably on
PC because Forge comes to the platform
became the platform with Windows 10 as
well as custom games so you can
essentially play like land games on PC
now just the first for the series sure
I'm online right sure yeah we Mary and I
did a stream last week the day before
the release we got like a early copy
which was nice but that game is cool man
like I'm excited to see where it goes I
mean it's you know it's halo 5
multiplayer free on PC mm-hmm that's
like kind of wild in itself the only
problems being that you know you're not
getting experience you're not raising
your level at all but you're still
enjoying the game in every aspect as far
as like the actually just separate from
you can't you can't do war zone or any
other other uh a few other types of game
modes I believe you can just do like
basic team battle or view for right or
no 8 on 8 okay is a per se but yeah cool
so 16 players but what's exciting just
for me is when I got to how have
hands-on with it and actually mess
around with the forge stuff because
again like you guys have seen it in like
on Reddit and all these places of these
gifts of these player made Forge maps
and they're freaking incredible the
amount of time people are putting in
they've revamped their whole forged
system make it easier you know you're
adding in what's called prefabs which
you can share prefabs being like I make
a base myself I just put it up and it's
like the speed and the intuitive nature
of it is so freakin quick we were we
play it'll probably like I don't know
two dozen Maps and this man of the
stream that we're all player made and
you can make your own so I can take a
prefab and bring it down so I don't have
to spend the hours on end making a base
it's really great and
I'm actually really excited to see how
well it does because I I would imagine
it would do well mouse and keyboard
control really great for you know making
maps and everything
yeah and they you know and here's the
other thing is like John Luke here
actually showed me there's like a
subreddit - for destiny because one of
the problems being hey say I do not have
Halo 5 on Xbox I don't have any Xbox
Live friends that's a problem I'm not
going to play multiplayer I gotta find
people in order to join a fireteam
what's cool is that despite them making
a update soon they said they're gonna
make a custom matchmaking ability which
is huge you can still right now go into
a subreddit and just find a fireteam
there are tons and tons of people who
are like hey you want to play let's
friend up just join this and jean-luc
was saying he was playing like all week
on all weekend long playing these
awesome four names well that's like what
titanfall 2 is implementing with
networks right to extend the longevity
of or the I guess the lifespan of a
multiplayer shooter which drops
considerably which this is what the 9th
update our 8th for Halo 5 the 9th right
Anvil's legacy yeah and obviously like a
big point of the update is Halo 5 like
worth returning to now whether on
consoles especially obviously on PC it's
the first chance you'll have on PC but I
don't know does have their updates been
doing a good job of drawing you back in
I know you're playing periodically new
and I do see em every once in a while
yeah I I definitely put in a couple
hours whenever I can
for each update it's it's a back and
forth thing I definitely enjoy it I
don't to say I think I think it's mostly
I think I just need friends to play with
maybe two if I don't I don't have
friends but you know they add new Maps
they add new weapons so it's fun to try
out those like they added a new a ship
called the wasp that's really fun to use
this is just a rich white person you fly
around on the sense of the acronym wasp
oh you insinuating like
microtransactions oh we should just roll
that sideways yeah yeah go for cards and
stuff pecan pie yeah I don't know
there's something about those cards that
is so is so unappealing to me like every
time
I finish a match it's like open this
pack boom daddy look at all this and
then you get into the menu I got to open
them and then I am just I'm sick and
tired of constantly seeing numbers of
like how much it takes and then money
yeah and the money thing is just killing
me with my transactions in my face and I
I just find that frustrating I know but
there's that but in general it's a fun
ass game and I'm more inclined the
updates are great and actually think
they do a great job of delivering those
people are who are huge Halo fans have a
have respected that however I'm more
into this Forge idea I think this is
going to take off they're really set in
a nice groundwork for some community
involvement and there's already been one
now it's ever so gonna grow like it's
exciting to me I mean you've seen the
map so just to touch on the maps that
like you've seen right like I think
there's one job it was I mean the people
have made three we went to three for
three recently had to do kind of a
feature on this and come to Windows 10
and they weren't allowed to promote
forge with other properties content but
they showed us like someone had made an
indoor map like treehouse is kind of in
the walkways the intro they did a whole
interesting medical r2d2 and they showed
Vader burning they put a Spartan and
like a black Spartan on his back and it
had flames so it was really great so no
sorries a funeral pyre yeah yeah so as
you know when return the Jedi there's
like that wish that don't don't do this
Vader and he's like you know that's Luke
looking over Baker in his helmets
charred up someone like recreated that
whole thing and it's hilarious like
that's your intro to the match we're not
gonna control the cameras one I'm
familiar with Forge yes we made it he
made he put mist in its indoor trees
with platforms and you're flying around
oh that is hilarious
it's sure we've got like our tutitu one
time and then it's like Vader died you
know what's up spartans leaping between
treehouses and kind of falling off a lot
there was yeah there's a giant foosball
table which they said you know like a
big point with the mouse and keyboard
controls now is you have much more
fine-tuned control over the level editor
itself you can actually change the
mathematics of
man cannon so you can do a 45-degree
angle as opposed to like a 35 for
example but the foosball table I don't
understand how it work but that was also
made in like four hours by someone on
their halo 5 QA team that had never
worked with Forge before so that's why
it was appealing to me I haven't gotten
the chance to play it much I know you
did a stream yes we can we you know the
game wasn't even released and we there
was all this stuff already available I
just think it's gonna really
exponentially grow and the other thing
too is there are these devoted fans and
just imagining 16 people just like
frantically working and building these
elaborate Maps yeah and now with the
ability to just drop in some guy made us
like a Star Destroyer you just drop that
in like podracing right some guys like
hey I have all the pod racers that hook
up a ghost they don't but make your own
map and you know recreate you know
Episode one pod racing from 16 hours
this is halo 5 that's right yeah
so I'm excited for that stuff one thing
I do want to touch on that the chat has
kind of been saying jokingly but I it
might be worth talking about so they're
making Microsoft making a big push for
Windows 10 I know if your alternate
edition was the first game and then you
know from here on out if I'm not
mistaken every Xbox one game or every
Windows 10 game you buy will be you'll
have it for free on the other platform
or maybe it's Xbox one to PC to Windows
10 so they play on I think that recore
is the very first game where it's
crossed by okay so where you buy it you
get it definitely for both platforms I
think for Gears you could you had to
like buy it on both but you could cross
here or something like that yeah and
from what I remember yaksa that was when
we did the review of the game but yeah
if I'm not mistake that the halo 5 the
update on PC is kind of tedious and
people are wondering if this is just I'm
a half-hearted attempt to bring people
to Windows 10 even more it's Windows 10
unfortunately it's you know it's it's
got some bad rap we've all seen pop up
on our PC at one but what surprised me
was that you had to opt for the
anniversary edition update which does
not do anything significant worse or
anything bad to your operating system
but it still required a like I my home
computer is not all that great
especially we're especially with
internet speed there took me like two
hours
download this anniversary update um but
again I mean I don't know I think I'm
pretty sure like I don't know I think
your your computer can be opted into
already like you may already have the
anniversary update is what I found out
later it just depends on like whether
you have that unlocked in your update
and settings on UPC I don't know either
way it's bigger than just like a
firmware patch for your driver patch for
your graphics card I mean it's a whole
update us just to get this game to play
sure yeah and it's not that great I mean
I'm not saying that's like it's brush
past that idea but it's still worth
saying that like I know they're making a
cool push for for Halo forge namely um
but yeah sure it's your choice if you
want to do that update or not I mean I
don't have any problems with it yeah
hopefully you know like in Halo 5 we'll
have a little more blood in its veins
until we get to like Halo Wars - for
those of us interested in it and then
the eventual halo 6 which they've said
will be on PC right from launch and
leave so that'll be a first for them but
anyway yeah that's table 5 Guardians
Forge mode on PC and Windows 10th now if
you plan on playing it if you plan on
checking out for words if you're a big
fan of fours on consoles and want to try
it on PC I'll leave your thoughts in the
comments below